was this story going to die down or is
there another shoe to drop yeah i think
as more information comes out it's
certainly a huge story and then you know
one once training camp starts we'll see
i'll Laremy Tunsil fits in but i mean
first of all huge steel for the dolphins
and I I feel bad for this kid really
unfortunate events that occurred on
draft night that probably cost him at
least 12 million dollars do we have any
more information on who hacked his
account yet from what I've heard the
Dolphins believe it was a former
financial advisor of Laremy Tunsil so
you know the way I'm you know I don't
have a name yet of who this is but you
know the way I'm imagining how it goes
down this is a guy who Laremy Tunsil had
worked with we don't know how reputable
of a financial advisor he was obviously
you can't think he's too reputable if he
would hack him like this but probably
the guys in line to make a ton of money
once Laremy Tunsil gets in traffic
Tunsil fires him and the guy hacked him
and when I sought out to destroy his
career the moments before the biggest
dog time of life when sun soul meets
with the local media with the dolphins
are there questions topics that are
off-limits yeah we haven't been told
that no but he's clearly he clearly
talked to the PR staff he's not saying
anything you know when he had an
introductory press conference he just
repeatedly said I'm blessed to be with
the dolphins I'm blessed to be with the
dolphins obviously that was a day after
the disastrous press conference after
the draft where he was honest and he
admitted that yes he had accepted some
money from coaches at Ole Miss uh
unfortunately for him a little too
honest so I imagine we're going to see
him guarded off for the time being I'm
just shocked that after he got drafted
he was he he was having a press
conference there because nobody really
cared that he you know about his
football talents it was unfolding right
in front of us in real time how did he
get in front of the press in the first
place yeah I mean I think everyone is in
Chicago has a press conference there and
like you said this was in real time and
this has never happened
we've never had a situation where
moments before the draft something
damaging like this is leaked on social
media and I think that's what happened
with the other NFL teams you know teams
and GM's can go months and months of
draft preparation they are ready to come
draft night there's not a lot of
surprises they might get some trade
offers but they have their board they
have their information they're ready
there's never been a situation like this
where right before the dress they
suddenly have to scramble and I think
teams a lot of these teams you know
freaked out they didn't know what to
make of it they saw the photo it's not
just a guy smoking a joint I mean this
was a bong and a gas mask it looks bad I
think teams got scared and that's why
you saw him fall on the board but the
Dolphins they saw it as a steal they had
done their homework and they said you
know what we're going to take this guy
even if we take a temporary PR hit any
local criticism of this draft pick you
know I think there's a little bit you
hear some people especially after you
gotta remember the Dolphins drafted Dion
Jordan number three and he's had a lot
of drug problems failed his third drug
test he's been a huge bust so I think
some people are thinking Dion Jordan but
the difference of this stick is Laremy
Tunsil has never failed a drug test I
think most people out there realize hey
you college kids smoke pot NFL players
smoke pot isn't a huge shocker he let
himself get filmed he was vulnerable he
got hacked and it went out there but the
fact that he's never actually failed a
drug test you know I don't think there's
too many fears I think most people
locally say hey this worked out well for
the Dolphins Andrew thanks for joining
us we appreciate it thanks for having me
andrew abramson palm beach post the
Dolphins reporter the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience